hi there Steve Goffin here again to talk
about language learning which is a
subject that I find fascinating that's
become a big part of my life the last 15
years or so and today I want to talk
about a few subjects that are related in
my mind it has to do with intermediate
content which is a major problem for
language learners there's a lot of
beginner content and it's easy to access
authentic content newspapers you know
Netflix videos but it's difficult to get
from the beginner content where
obviously there's a lot of
high-frequency verb or words from there
to being able to actually enjoy the
authentic content so how do we fill the
gap what I'm finding in my Persian is
that I've asked this Iranian or several
Iranians to create stories or to create
episodes where they talk about
themselves who they are what they like
to do their professional life what they
studied their interests in different
sports or cooking or whatever it might
be to speak naturally and then to
transcribe I've mentioned this before
and I think we're gonna get some
dialogues as well where people just talk
to each other and then transcribe so
this is natural content but one of the
advantages of the many stories which is
where I you know start into any language
is the amount of repetition because we
have the sort of point of view different
tense or different person
covering essentially the same story and
then followed by questions and the
questions of course are simply more
exposure because they begin with a
statement of something from the story
and then they ask you to say where why
or yes or no without forcing you to try
and think about what happened in the
story which is something that I find
quite annoying because I sometimes can't
remember all I really want is that you
know three times a triple repetition of
essentially this
same vocabulary with some change you
know going from a statement to a
question or positive to negative and so
forth so that works really well so I've
asked Safra who is my Iranian
collaborator to create questions for
these you know rambles of hers where she
talks about herself and what she likes
to do and it really improves them
because it makes it easier to focus on
the vocabulary in the original monologue
and it's easier to understand the
original monologue so it drives you back
into the story I've mentioned this
before I would like to get people to
help me figure out how we can create
this kind of content we have a series in
link called the Iranians can we have one
for I don't know the the Parisians the
québécois the Brazilians that the
Pekinese I don't know the Russians
anything where a group of people can get
together record a 5-minute little
monologue or a dialogue then create ten
questions in this format statement
question about the statement and then
answer repeating the same vocabulary we
will be I will be happy to compensate
people I would love to start getting
this kind of content into link and/or we
make it available to people we would use
it in link but other people can use it
however they want so I would be very
interested in doing that now people have
pointed out that this is a technique
called circling or it relates to a
technique called circling the point of
view stories the circling all of these
things come from a variety of teaching
techniques in the sort of t p RS
teaching proficiency through reading and
storytelling and there are variants on
this theme it's the sort of
comprehensible input approach to
language learning now I have I'm gonna
leave two links in the description box
two articles that describe this circling
questions technique and just the two
that I look at in preparation for this
video and which I you know I'm leaving
the links here in the description box
this very much describes a teaching
technique now my perspective as a
learner as an independent learner and
when I look at other independent
learners who are mostly 18 years and
older you know our situation and our
needs as learners our needs are
different from the position of a teacher
who has to amuse the classroom I mean I
remember as a kid in class we were just
as much interested in interacting with
our friends in the classroom as in
listening to the teacher so the teacher
has to grab our attention somehow and in
one of the links you'll see there's a
video of an example of a circling you
know question type class for Spanish but
but typically the the emphasis there the
teacher has to teach something so the
teacher uses these circling questions to
help you know give the learners more
exposure more repetition for certain
specific structures that they're trying
to get across it's almost like a form of
drilling it's trying to drill home
certain structures so that keeps the
kids occupied and undoubtedly teaches
them something but that's not what I'm
looking for my experience as a learner
is that if I'm being drilled in a
certain structure or even if circling
questions are being used to provide that
repetition that necessary repetition in
a structure my brain starts that you
know tune out and that very often these
structures that I want to learn I'm
going to learn them over a long period
of time by coming across those
structures in different scenarios in
different bits of content so that my
goal is to simply consume a lot of
content confident that eventually the
structures are gonna are gonna you know
fall into place I might occasionally
look up
explanations or see examples you know
concentrated examples of these
structures but mostly I'm relying on my
listening and reading to you know make
it possible for my brain to start to tie
some of these ends together and
recognize these these patterns so what
I'm looking for is not so much the sort
of something that would captivate a
classroom of little kids but rather
stories monologues that are in of
themselves interesting so we're meeting
one and then Jose and then Maria and
we're meeting different people from
other know Venezuela or you know Peru
who talk about who they are and what
they do which is interesting because if
we're interested in the language we're
interested in the people and so these
are natural monologues or dialogues but
then to make sure we can better
understand these stories we follow up
with these say ten or twelve questions
and so that it's it's not so much
listening to a teacher in the classroom
to try and nail down some structure it's
rather natural you know input
comprehensible interesting input made
more comprehensible because we have
these follow-up questions which actually
don't require us to think of anything is
just more exposure to the language so
have a look at the have a look at the
the links there just to understand this
this technique which is used with great
success I think in classrooms but what I
would really like to know is if anyone
can send me an email steve at link calm
if you can get together with some people
whether it be at your university place
of work a bunch of friends and we will
compensate you might be money might be
membership names i don't know but they
have to be good like they have to be
good it can't be you know you've got a
list of ten things my sports my food my
this and it sort of becomes a humdrum
you know going through the motions the
idea is to get interesting
almost like many biographies of people
in the language group you know whose
language we're learning and then to help
us understand these better we add these
questions at the end
and if we can get lots of these I think
that's a very good sort of intermediate
type of content it becomes intermediate
because when people speak naturally they
tend to use less difficult words it
could be compelling because we learn
about different people we have to meet
different people and it can become more
comprehensible if we have these
questions at the end and I think that'll
kind of move us towards better you know
to becoming better at using authentic
content although I would also like to
try you know if people are willing to
help us you know provide these kinds of
questions for you know genuine authentic
you know material like transcribe
podcast and stuff of that nature but
anyway this is what I'm interested in
seeing how far we explore this idea I
look forward to hearing from you Steve
at MIT calm
[Music]